nobody has insight at this stage because
the Iranian campaign is it's a much
shorter campaign than the u.s. campaign
we now now our campaigns are two years
long and you start getting a feel for
the candidates you start getting an
understanding of where it's going to go
you have poles you have all kinds of
things Iran has poles too and President
Ahmadinejad is particularly unpopular
right now his popularity ratings
according to unofficial polls is sit
somewhere around where George Bush's was
at the end of his presidency in the
twenty five to thirty percent range so
he is deeply unpopular mainly because of
his economic performance and because of
the economy in Iran and there are other
factors too now that doesn't mean he
can't win the campaign season itself is
a very short season the Iranian new year
is in March coming out of New Year that
there's a two-week holiday it's kind of
like Christmas for us by the beginning
of April the candidates will start
setting out their agendas they've
already started a little bit in terms of
giving speeches and going to
universities and kind of setting out
there a little bit of their agenda but
there'll be this fury of activity flurry
of activity and a furious activity for
the last two weeks three weeks of the
campaign and so many things can happen
with Iran between now and then between
now and May which is when that's going
to happen that it's really hard to say
something you know there could be an
outside force that makes the turns the
election one way or another if the
United States for example opens up a
dialogue with Iran that could affect the
election one way or another at the
United States does something else you
know intimidating to Iran that could
have helped Ahmadinejad for example if
the Israelis and there'll be a new prime
minister in Israel within weeks
presumably Benjamin Netanyahu if they
really government does something that
could potentially help out Medina we
don't know there's so many unknown
factors right now the reality is I think
that most people in Iran would like to
see some sort of change
the thing that would surprise many
Americans is that the elections are
actually quite free and you know in Iran
some American journalists described them
as you know free relative to Middle
Eastern elections but that's really not
true in Egypt you know what if Hosni
Mubarak wants to be reelected he gets a
ninety nine percent positive vote that
doesn't happen in Iran the election for
president is actually quite quite free
when I say quite free there's always
going to be some sort of shenanigans on
some level even in the United as there
are even in the United States you know
whether it's whether it's completely
illegal activity stuffing ballot boxes
which can happen but not to a large
degree or there's intimidation of voters
and things like that which happens even
in the United States but by and large
they're very free so when unless an
election is is decided by very very
small margin less than 200,000 votes in
a population in a country where there's
70 million people and and you know 40
million can vote 50 million can vote
then then it's really a true truly free
election for the for the president
I think it's the pocketbook you know
it's it's like everybody every country
in the world Iranians are not that
different from from Americans yes I
think the economy is going to be the
number one issue I think to the degree
that international relations and the
nuclear issue affect the economy it
becomes more of a factor it's not so
much that o our we deciding whether we
want to go ahead and have nuclear energy
the way that Ahmadinejad proposes it or
do we want to back down in front of
America it's not that it's more about
well how is this affecting our economy
how is this affecting the sanctions how
is this affecting unemployment and
Iranians are you know quite smart about
that they understand that when for
example and certainly the elite
understand that when President
Ahmadinejad you know had goes on
television and or at a speech somewhere
some says something you know very
inflammatory about Israel or about
America and gives America the
opportunity to go to the Security
Council and gives America a better
excuse to impose sanctions other
countries will go along with it they
understand that that kind of rhetoric is
not necessarily helpful whether or not
the intention of the government of Iran
is to pursue nuclear energy or not so
those issues are going to be debated by
certainly amongst the the educated elite
and I think even you know trickling down
all the way to the poor who understand
that the isolation of Iran not from the
rest of the world so much but certainly
from America has affected the economy
you